تقترب المذنبات من الارض بشكل متكرر فبعض
المذنبات تمر كل بدعه عقود لكن حديث في
الفضاء لهذا الاسبوع لا يمر كل عشره اعوام
او 100 او 1000 بل 50.000
المذنب الاخضر يمر عبر الارض لاول مره منذ
العصر الجليد الاخير المذنب تم اكتشافه في
مارس من العام الماضي
التكنولوجيا بس سميه بالمذنب الاخضر لانه
شعره
[موسيقى]
المذنب رصده البعض بالعين المجرده دون
الاستعانه بتلسكوب ومن المفترض ان يمر
باقرب نقطه له الى الارض فوق القطب
الشمالي اليوم الاربعاء قبل ان يبتعد في
طريق الى خارج النظام الشمسي يوم الخميس
فجرا بتوقيت الولايات المتحده
فحجز مقاعدك وحاول ان لا تفقده اثناء
رحلته عبر كوكبنا ولو حتى بمتابعه بث
مباشر لحظه بلحظه عبر الانترنت فيحتما
ستكون الفرصه الاخيره التي نتمكن من
مشاهدته فيها قبل ان يزورنا ثانيه بعد
50,000 عام
[موسيقى]